I just wanted to lead you through a
little bit of the research that I've
been doing on the kind of metal level
around long lived institutions and and
then also just some observations of some
of the way various systems have lasted
for hundreds or thousands of years I
wanted to start with this slide it's
actually one of the early things I
worked with Stewart on that long now
just kind of you know defining our
problem space and you know what what do
we really think about in different
scales often you know companies are
generally they're working at least in
the nowadays we would like to think and
that's been shortening to some extent
obviously with kind of more quarterly
thoughts than then decade level thoughts
but in defining what the long now was
and I mentioned that Peter was the one
who suggested this 10,000 year timeframe
originally Danny's idea for this clock
was the millennium clock and it would
kind of tick one say once a year and
bung once a century and the cuckoo would
come out once a millennium but he didn't
really have you know what was the end
date of that and this 10,000 year thing
is you look at Caen global
civilizational rise was you know when
the the last interglacial period ended
and we had agriculture we had these
first cities and I just want to point
out that that is about 8,000 BC 10,000
years ago and I think one of the best
observations that Stewart really made
about what long now is is that if we can
look back that far for that far we
should be able to look forward that far
and that if we think about ourselves in
the middle of a twenty thousand years
story it's very different than thinking
about ourselves as the end of a ten
thousand year story right but I wanted
you to think about that 8,000 BC number
as we move through this this was the
other I think this was actually the very
first thing I worked on it long now this
came out of a discussion between Stewart
and Brian Eno and it was kind of trying
to tease apart
these layers of human time and we had
the chalkboard robot draw it as well but
I think you can look at institutions on
this thing too right so you could map an
institution across this like if you look
at you know Apple Computer let's say you
know they've got they're coming out with
new iPhones every you know six months
that's out there on the fashion level
and then the commerce is them selling
those things the infrastructure is that
cell phone networks and the chip fabs
that that's all built on the governance
now this is governance not governed
meant they're mostly working with
governments but they also have to work
with general governing systems and
that's a little bit of what sam o is
mentioning that now some of these
companies are hitting walls against
whole different types of governments or
who have different ideas of privacy
different ideas of commercialization
that they're actually now having to
shape their companies around that and
then obviously culture is a little bit
obscured here is moving slower
underneath all of this but they're
they're starting to affect culture and
then the last one being nature moving
the slowest at some point they're gonna
have to come to terms with the level of
environmental damage and problems that
that are happening on the natural level
as well if they're going to be a company
that lasts for a hundred years or a
thousand years so we can we could
imagine like any large institution
mapped across this and I think it's a
it's a useful tool for that also very
early on in long now's history case
Vander Heiden who was a famous scenario
but he wrote the book on scenario
planning he he came to a Charette that
that long now organized to kind of come
up what is the long now business idea so
this is dated nineteen nine nineteen
ninety seven as a few months after I
started it long now and I thought it's
it was Katherine actually refound this
when she joined the board from her
research package he began when when he
published this and it was strangely
prophetic basically all these Square
areas are the ones where we have core
competencies the dotted lines are the
ones that are temporary like the
founders and then the things that appear
are all the things that we hadn't really
gotten to yet and figured out like we
didn't have a
we didn't have a way of funding
ourselves we didn't have a membership
program we didn't have a large community
of donors we didn't have an endowment
which we are still don't have actually
but and we didn't have people willing to
give their estates to us yet and we
still don't have that but that's kind of
now that we've been around for 22 years
we can imagine how those things are
gonna start to happen next and then I
also want to point out the cyclical
nature of this and that's gonna I think
kind of come up a lot today there's no
system in the world that I've found that
is linear that has lasted on these
timescales you need to have a kind of a
cyclical business model not a not a
linear business model and I've been kind
of collecting all of the longest-lived
institutions in the world and as you as
you look at these I think there's
there's a few things that come out of
this and notice brewery brewery winery
hotel bar pub right and also notice that
a lot of them are in Japan you will that
you know there's been a system of rough
system of government there for over
2,000 years with the with the way the
royal family has worked that's held
together enough that has allowed
something like the royal confectioner of
Japan to be one of the oldest companies
in the world but there's also temple
builders and things like that now in
Western companies I think what's really
interesting is that most of the
companies that have survived for a very
long time are basically service
companies and so they've it's you can
imagine it's a lot easier to reinvent
yourself as a service-oriented company
than it is as a commodity company when
that particular commodity stops being a
thing right and so I think but the
definitely the things like Palmolive are
a little bit of out of that example but
they've they're a broad enough company
and DuPont is a broad enough company
that they can change the kind of
products that they sell over time and I
think I'd be interesting to learn more
about all of these companies and
that's and so they probably all have
some kind of special sauce bit of their
story but the other thing I want to
point out to you is is this
parenthetical here that has that came
out of some of this research that
basically the the length of companies
lives at this point is shrinking at
almost one year per year right so in in
1950 the average company on the fortune
500 was or had been around for 61 years
and now that's actually this data is a
little bit out of date now now it's 18
years so company's lives are getting
shorter in the fortune 500 yes correct
so as I mentioned most of the oldest
companies in the world in this case
survey of the 5500 companies over 200
years old are are in Japan the the rest
are in some of the older countries in
Europe but this was a really curious
fact to me and I think it's gonna speak
to part of the the the the cyclical
nature of things is that ninety percent
of the companies that are over 200 years
old are under 300 employees they're not
mega companies and so if you and then
surveying a thousand companies over 300
years old
you know what is their what is their
industry and it's there's a there's a
huge amount of disparity in those
industries but there was a few big
groupings that I thought was really
interesting basically alcohol and that
doesn't even include pubs and
restaurants that sell it and hotels and
things like that is is one of the
largest segments here and I think what's
also really interesting is that Patrick
McGovern and biomolecular archaeologists
who I talk to when we're building this
place they he's done DNA analysis on
wine on vines which are clonal species
which I'll talk about a little bit later
and basically we know from that analysis
that civilization started cultivating
wine 8,000 BC
so there's this very interesting
correlation and and he he actually
supposes that it's not at all clear if
civilization stopped being nomadic in
order to ferment things or because they
started fermenting things they stopped
being nomadic and but it's a it's a very
interesting correlation and that some of
the you know this overwhelmingly large
segments of the oldest companies in the
world deal in this ones one part of it
universities are on here as well which I
think are an interesting one they also
have this curious way of renewing
themselves and we'll talk a little bit
about that but I also want to talk a
little bit about values right there's
not all long term institutions are being
long term is not inherently good and I
think early on it long now we've always
said you know it's all about just
long-term thinking and we're not trying
to ascribe a lot of values to it but
that's that's I don't think that's
intellectually honest and I think that
we do have to think what are we trying
to perpetuate we have to step back at it
far enough that we you know we want to
make sure that the kind of things that
we're perpetuating are generally good
for society some of the ways that things
have lasted for a really long time is
just to take a really long time to build
them cathedrals our famous example of
this and I think the the most dangerous
time for for anything that that's
lasting is really just one generation
after it was built right so it's now
it's not you're it's it's not a new cool
thing it's the thing that your parents
did and it's not cool anymore and it's
not until you know another couple
generations later or everyone values its
values it only because or not only but
largely because it is old and venerable
and this this kind of cultural icon and
we already you know see this was this
Cathedral here it's 125 years into its
built process and it's already a UNESCO
World Heritage Site and I think find
that's really interesting that a thing
that is actually under construction is a
unesco world heritage site it's not done
and I think that's that's interesting in
and of itself the other way things last
for really own time obviously and this
is the the Japanese model is that
they're just extremely well maintained
these are the two oldest continuously
Stan
wooden structures in the world about
1,400 years old I was I was there a few
years ago and they've replaced a lot of
things they keep the roof on it and in
even and it took a totally humid and
rain raining environment and these
buildings that central Timbers have
stayed true interestingly this this
temple was also the place where a
Japanese princess over he was over a
thousand years ago had a vision that she
needed to descend this a particular
prayer out to the world and make sure
that it survived into the future and so
she had literally a million wooden
pagodas turned and lathes and a little
message the prayer put inside it and
distributed them as far and wide as she
could and we still today you can buy
them on eBay right now and so they're
it's a it was an interesting early
example of kind of lots of copies keep
stuff stick keeps stuff safe and Tim's
distribution idea another Japanese
example that uses a totally different
strategy is a Shinto shrine that was an
early example to us here at long now and
just a few years ago we actually went
for the the next rebuilding so Shinto is
an animist religion where they believe
that spirits are in everything rather
than the the Buddhism that came in later
but the temples that in the Shinto
belief system have this renewing
technology if you will that is where
they're rebuilt in in a site right next
to each other and so in different
periodicity
this one which was the most famous in
japan at esa the grand shrine has
rebuilt every 20 years you'll also
notice that one of the oldest companies
in the world is a temple building
company from Japan and that is the
company that builds these temples and so
this is a different way where it's not
so much that it's maintained but it's
actually renewed and so this you know
these these temples made of thatch and
would totally ephemeral materials have
for now 2,000 years they have documented
evidence of exactly rebuilding for 1600
years but this site was founded in 4 ad
also by a visionary princess in Japan
and every 20 years they they move the
treasures from one from one temple to
the other and the princess of Japan
comes and does that and the the that the
comi the spirits follow that and then
they deconstruct the temple the old one
and they send all those parts out to
various shinto temples in Japan as kind
of religious artifacts the I think the
most important thing about this
particular example is that it's also
extremely important that each generation
gets to have this this moment where the
older master teaches the apprentice the
thing right so you get this handing off
of knowledge that's extremely physical
and real and has a deliverable it's got
a ship right like the princess is coming
to move the stuff like we have to do
this it's an eight year process with
tons of ritual that goes into rebuilding
these temples I think an interesting
counter example two things lasting a
very long time is when they ascribe to
certain ideologies and I think it's
curious you know one of our longest
lived institutions is the Catholic
Church but we also see and the ideology
of something like the Buddha's of
Bamiyan here has lasted but a lot of the
artifacts become targets for for people
who don't believe in that ideology you
can see how small these people are the
Taliban spent weeks dynamiting and using
artillery to destroy these these
Buddha's and even when you look at
something like Buddhism it's a pretty
innocuous religion that is I would think
is very unthreatening but not so much to
the Taliban and universities have this
ability to do this kind of continual
refresh where every four years
especially in undergraduate programs you
have a whole new set of people and so
they they kind of have to
sell themselves to a new generation
every single year which is a I think
causes you know their customer is is a
whole class and we see universities now
struggle when they when they aren't
teaching relevant things to people and
they have to adjust and and that has
kept them around as some of the
longest-lived institutions in the world
this is the University of Bologna which
is largely credited as the the earliest
university in the world and it's it's
almost a thousand years old at this
point
Oxford was shortly behind it and there's
another you know 40 or so universities
over five hundred years old I think the
ideas of communities of practice is a
really interesting one the we we
definitely have evidence of martial arts
in all kinds of ways that that have
lasted at least two or three thousand
years but really it was in some ways was
always practicing for war so I think it
goes back to the the dawning of human
civilization but we we at least have
this documented part of this where truly
you know exacting knowledge is handed
down from generation to generation
through communities of practice like in
martial arts and then moving to nature a
little bit and I know that Eric's gonna
be talking a fair amount about natural
systems but I wanted to kind of go over
them there's several strategies in
nature that allow things to last for
thousands of years there's clonal
strategies like the aspen tree or we we
know that mesquite we've we've measured
mesquite rings in the desert where they
die and then they grow up in a ring from
the root structure that indicates that a
mesquite ring has been as the same DNA
effectively for fifty thousand years and
these clonal forests have have
definitely been around for for thousands
of years even though each individual
will only last a few years in some cases
and other cases things are cultivated
and going back to the the wine example
where we we know we have effectively
that the DNA of of clonal species like
these these grapes from ancient Rome
where we have taken a clipping and
cultivated it from generation to
generation so
Ben this kind of interplay between
humans and and the natural world and we
also see this and in a lot of kind of
tree carrying practices and I think
what's really curious about this
particular example as it goes right back
to what Stuart and and Peter were just
talking about of how an existential
crisis gives you practice in terms of
how you're going to survive and the the
Bristlecone is the oldest continuously
living single organism that we know of
in the in the world as opposed to clonal
and the the funny thing about the
Bristlecone is it was it was not
discovered by coring to be the oldest
living species in the world
it was postulated because a particular
tree scientists had cored other pine
species and as they did that they found
that all the ones in the worst
environments were the oldest and he said
if you can find the pine species that is
living in the absolute worst environment
you will find the oldest species of pine
in the world and he coined this term
adversity brings longevity and so then
people went to go find the the pines in
the worst environment and up at the top
of the of the White Mountains and in the
snake range in Nevada and some in
Colorado as well they found three
different species of Bristlecone
effectively which have been dated to
over 5,000 years at this point so those
are some of the natural strategies and I
just want to talk I think it's worth us
kind of loading up a little bit on some
demographics and some changes that are
ahead if any of us are building an
institution that's going to last for the
next few hundred or a thousand years the
demographics and the climate are a big
part of it this is you know the
projected impact on agricultural yields
until the twenty 80s and as you can see
agricultural yields in the global south
are going to be going down in the global
north and the in much further north more
like Canada and Russia they're going to
be getting a lot better and this is
going to change the world markets world
populations what we're warring over
for the next hundred years for sure and
I think also coming back to this idea of
growth is that all you know in all
natural systems you have these sigmoid
curves that things always go down and we
always are ascribing things like our
population and our economies to always
going up but in that is not the way the
world works that has never been that way
and I think to semo's point we always
have these kind of Corrections and you
have you know in this case a predator
following the the prey as a lower
sigmoid once its prey runs out then the
Predators start dying off and and really
I think the interesting thing about this
is how does how do we get good at at
failing but not not totally dying out
right so the Lynx never dies out totally
but companies like that do one thing are
really bad at kind of recovering when
that one thing is is no longer the big
commodity right like it wasn't it wasn't
record companies that invented iTunes it
was it was an outsider company you know
record companies were super good at
selling plastic circles and when there
was no plastic circles to sell music on
they they all the people's jobs they
just didn't really know how to adjust
for that and I think I think this is
going to be the crux of anything that's
gonna last for a long time is how do you
get good at reinvention and retooling
and the other one is is really that the
the world there's no scenario that I've
seen in this this data is even out of
date where the world population doesn't
start going down by at least a hundred
years from now if not less than 50 years
from now so most the you know that even
the median one which is now five years
old it was starting to taper off that
red line in the middle but it's now
starting to increasingly look a lot more
like that dotted blue line at the bottom
there and the world has really never
lived through a time except for a few
short plague seasons where the world
population was going down customer base
was going down I think even more
dangerous than the the population going
down it's the population
changing so this is that the red line
here is the number of 15 to 64 year olds
on the right and the blue line is the
zero to 14 year olds if the world is is
made up largely of older people who
hoard wealth don't don't work hard and
don't you know don't make huge
contribute contributions of creativity
to the world the way 20 year olds do
that world is a world that I I don't
think we're really prepared to live in
right now and to just have one example
of it we we see it now happening in a
lot of the developed world and most
notably in Japan is that if those of you
remember the 80s there was no scenario
where Japan was not a absolute dominate
part of the economy of the world and now
they're struggling this to be relevant
in a lot of ways and it's largely
because this population thing happened
and this is the the young people were
not there they wouldn't allow any
immigration and that creativity and that
thrust of civilization really just kind
of went out of a country that was the
world power dominant world economic
power so I'm gonna leave us there to
grab lunch and thank you very much
[Music]
you